netflix has already renewed you for a
fourth season and after the devastating
season three finale we've got a ton of
theories about what comes next for joe
goldberg yupikai movie lovers i'm jan
and in this video i'll be discussing the
best theories and predictions for season
four and beyond and what the chances are
that joe's crimes will finally catch up
with him spoilers and speculation ahead
of course so take care
the season 3 finale ends with joe
fleeing the us for france however
there's a little clue in the final scene
that hints it might not be as easy as
joe expects to escape the attention of
his fellow countrymen when he overhears
two americans in the parisian cafe
talking about how so many new yorkers
have left the city i think this is a big
tease that we'll get to see some
characters connected to joe's old life
in the big apple crossing paths with him
in paris first of all there's ethan
joe's colleague from mooney's bookshop
his girlfriend blythe beck's friends
annika and lynn and there's a salinger
family who we know from peach owns an
apartment there cousin inez finally
vacated the paris flat the salangers
also had a pi investigating the
circumstances of peach's death who
interviewed joe in new york because they
suspected some kind of foul play karen
minty joe's ex-girlfriend also said she
wanted to visit the french capital when
paco was talking about where in the
world he'd like to go if he could go
anywhere i would go to paris any of
these people would surely recognize joe
if they came across him and i wouldn't
put it past him murdering any of them or
at least locking them up in a new cage
or basement to stop his secret getting
out a character who's likely to come
back into joe's life is ellie who had to
flee la to get away from the quinns
after her sister delilah's murder at the
end of season two from the sarasota
postmark on the postcard that joe
received from her she appears to have
gone to florida and in season three joe
mentions that he's still secretly
sending her money to keep her off the
quinn's radar i send the profits to
ellie now something to remember is that
ellie only knows joe by his pseudonym
will so she doesn't know his real name
is joe goldberg however ellie's pretty
smart and savvy so i think she would get
suspicious when she hears news reports
about love quinn killing joe goldberg
and pictures start appearing of the
apparently dead man she knows as well
and if joe keeps sending her money i'm
sure she'll figure out there's something
iffy about what happened in madre linda
so i wouldn't be surprised if she
started investigating things she may
even work out some details of joe's
murderous past in new york because she
was after all involved in the scriptory
rite of forty's planned adaptation of
beck's book during the crazy events of
that night forty figured out that dr
nicki was actually innocent and the
beck's ex-boyfriend was the real killer
we murdered her in a jealous rage and he
framed dr nikki how much of this
epiphany did 40 share with ellie we
don't know yet but i suspect we may find
out in season four or a future season i
killed henderson and i don't feel guilty
about it leave a thumbs up if you'd like
to see ellie return in the season three
finale we see joe has a new alias nick
which could be a nod to dr nikki who he
framed for beck's murder in the season
one finale and i think we're still not
done with dr nicki's storyline in the
series because the way joe plants a box
with natalie's teeth to ensure love's
blamed for the carnage and madre linda
is uncannily similar to the suggestion
beck had for framing dr nikki in her
book there's this part where i talk
about a box of mementos that i found on
nikki's property a jar
of tea what if someone on the free dr
nikki subreddit reads details about love
quinn's supposed murder suicide and
connects it with what happened to dr
nicki and they figure out that it was
really joe behind the fatal stabbing of
ryan goodwin and now he's pinned that
murder on his dead wife also what about
the salinger family pi who didn't
believe what he read in beck's book that
dr nikki was guilty maybe not everyone
was completely convinced although dr
nikki told forty he didn't want to get
involved in looking into joe if he
killed beck there's no telling what this
man is capable of he'll be punished but
not by us trust and divine justice
perhaps he'll decide he's had enough now
of being the full guy for joe's crimes
in new york and will get someone to come
after him something joe worried about
briefly in season two this is bad love
plainclothes cop dr nikki what's he got
on me joe's also in paris of course
because he's searching for marianne who
fled after love revealed that he'd been
lying to her and had killed her
ex-husband ryan though we don't know for
sure yet that marienne's in france it's
certainly plausible as she told joe she
was born in paris and would go there to
get away from her ex joe wonders at the
end of season three whether he'll be
able to win marianne back and convince
her that love's warnings were wrong
however i think marianne understands now
just how toxic joe is as she already
suspected it something in me knew that
it was too good to be true so i don't
think she'll delude herself that he's a
good guy in a bad situation as joe
frequently tells himself after all
she'll have likely seen the same news
stories as everyone else about what
happened including love's murder suicide
note and reports about dna evidence
showing joe died in the fire so if he
suddenly turned up on her doorstep now
he wouldn't exactly look innocent would
he assuming that marianne rejects joe
when he finds her it will be interesting
to see how he reacts and there's a
possible hint in season two in the end
our guy has to murder
all three women it's like the ultimate
irony that was from 40 screenplay bang
marry kill and it could be some deep
foreshadowing of joe's fate as he's
already killed two of the main women in
his life beck and love alternately and
perhaps optimistically might joe
remember what he really thought about
the ending of 40's screenplay that it
sounds like the most anti-feminist
horror film in history and if so could
he stop himself this time and find a way
to let marienne go or perhaps marianne
herself will find a way to put a
permanent end to joe's stalking days
theo could also return in season 4
because he's got concrete video evidence
that joe was involved in his
stepmother's murder as he uncovered
camera footage of him driving natalie's
car away on the day she disappeared theo
may initially assume like everyone else
that joe is dead however there'll surely
be traces of joe moving around madre
linda on the night of his supposed death
on various cameras in the town from
either doorbell cams or street cameras
recording him escaping his burning house
although love was responsible for theo's
injuries he was infatuated with her i
love you and if he suspects or figures
out that joe killed her he might start
looking to make him pay it's interesting
that as part of the story joe crafted
when he faked his own murder and love
suicide he decided to portray her as
what he called the mrs lovett of madre
linda by putting a piece of his own toe
into a pie before burning the house down
in the musical version of the sweeney
todd story the serial killing barber
burns mrs lovett alive but then her
younger assistant tobias who's very
attached to her gets revenge for her
murder by killing todd another person
who might have dirt on joe is love's
mother dotty we know the quinn family
shut down any investigation into
henderson's death and they covered up
love's murder of the au pair years
earlier so it's reasonable that dotty
might know where the bodies of love's
other victims were buried and what if
she figures out that jo might still be
out there and was responsible for her
daughter's death although her financial
assets aren't what they used to be she
could still find a way to frame joe for
any of love's crimes there was also a
cryptic moment in the second season when
dottie implied that the quinn's already
had knowledge of some of joe's dark
secrets your secrets are safe with us
it's also entirely possible that love
herself had some kind of revenge planned
for jo in the event of her untimely
death what did you do with her body or
delilah's i told you i took care of it
what if love had set up a way for joe to
get the blame for candace and delilah's
deaths in the event of her premature
demise perhaps the location of their
bodies together with evidence that could
incriminate joe will come to light a
kind of posthumous revenge on joe for
pinning everything that happened in
madrid linda on her including the death
of ryan which joe carried out by himself
of course now this next theory is a
little crazy but let's briefly entertain
the possibility that love is still alive
could she like joe have taken an
antidote before being injected with
aconite so that after he left the
burning house she too was able to get
out of there if so she'd have to lay low
as everyone's seen her fake confession
to the murders of natalie and ryan i
don't think this theory is very
plausible as it would diminish the
season 3 ending however crazier things
have happened on tv so i wouldn't
discard it entirely if the writers
wanted to introduce a huge twist in
season 4 or later where love suddenly
bursts back into joe's life seeking
revenge what i think's much more likely
though is that we'll see love return in
season 4 as part of a hallucination that
joe has similar to the one that he had
of back in season 2 or the one love had
of 40 this season and i break down
love's death and the shocking finale in
a lot more detail in my season 3 ending
explained video tap here to watch that
or follow the link in the video
description so do you have any theories
or predictions for season 4 and do you
think joe will eventually get caught if
so how comment with all your ideas below
and if you enjoyed this then a like and
a share are hugely appreciated you can
tap left for my full you playlist where
i'll be adding my next view video with
the easter eggs you missed in season
three or tap right for my ending
explained thanks for watching and see
you next time hippie guy movie lovers